est ce qu'on va pouvoir échapper aux
compliments
il va falloir faire quelque chose
lignières 23 1292 français ont été
testés positifs alors qu'une rumeur de
3e confinement plein sur la france ce
sont plusieurs scénarios qui vont d'un
maintien du cadre actuel jusqu'à un
confinement très serré deux camps
s'opposent ceux qui veulent agir vite et
à tout prix ou confinées pour éviter la
catastrophe du scientifique considérons
qu'on ne peut pas attendre que ça
commence par le confinement et ceux qui
prônent leur liberté et dénonce
l'inutilité d'un énième confinement je
pense qu'on n'est pas dans le sens de
l'urgence il n'y a pas que le
confinement comme moyen de ralentir la
circulation du virus
d'autres pistes sont à l'étude mais
alors que disent les chiffres
faut-il 1re confinement très serré le
docteur guy me mohamed et nicolas dupont
aignan se feront face ce soir pour
tenter de répondre à cette question il
est temps de siffler la fin de la
récréation guimauve à tête avec mme
mercier - jimmy l'amour mon pote
voilà merci merci nicolas dupont aignan
d'être avec nous des personnes non
résidentes debout la france merci de
répondre toujours à nos invitations et
il y a benjamin amaral la cgt qui est là
aussi qui est prof et bien sûr tout le
monde ici à un avis alors la fin du
magnéto c'est vous jimmy vous dites il
est temps de siffler la fin de la
récréation il ya des gens qui sont pour
ce couvre feu
il ya des gens qui sont contre juste
jimmy ce que vous pouvez dire à nos
téléspectateurs vers quoi on se dirige
parce que c'est vrai qu'on entend plein
de choses en résumé le problème c'est
qu'il ya plein de scénarios qui sont sur
la table et ça change de jour en jour
d'heure en heure mais puisqu'il faut
adapter c'est vrai que d'un côté il faut
confiné on le sait on n'a pas le choix
mais d'un autre côté des arbitrages et
c'est vrai que c'est très facile pour
moi de dire confie non sans oublier que
derrière et des entreprises qui
souffrent il ya des enjeux économiques
donc il faut comprendre que ça prenne du
temps en revanche confiné c'est
nécessaire pour trois raisons la
première c'est que le couvre-feu à 18
heures n'a pas marché donc c'était
l'objectif on avait dit il faut que le
coup alors même le gouvernant ils ont
dit que ça ce n'était pas mal mais ça me
paraît suffisamment remis 30 relais
l'épidémie la deuxième chose c'est que
pourquoi ce qui n'a pas marché puisque a
eu les variants et les variants un peu
redistribuer les cartes que le variant
anglais progresse de jour en jour sur le
territoire et si on attend mais on va
aboutir à une nouvelle catastrophe et
puis la dernière
c'est qu'on l'avait dit souvenez-vous
que pourrait ouvrir les bars les
restaurants une sorte de déconfinement
total il fallait qu'on ait 5000
contamination par jour pour deux raisons
la première c'est pour contrôler
l'épidémie
c'est ce qui nous permet de tester tracé
et isoler correctement le problème c'est
qu'avec le niveau actuel de
contamination on ne peut pas tester
tracé le virus et donc on perd le
contrôle
et puisque on oublie et ce qui est
peut-être la chose la plus importante
c'est que quand on dit qu'on veut avoir
5000 contamination par jour c'est qu'on
veut avoir peu de morts et dans la plus
grande indifférence générale on a
l'équivalent des arabes us a380 qui
s'écrase tous les jours avec 300 à 400
morts par jour mais d'une façon
quasiment normal on parle de beaucoup de
chiffres mais on oublie que dr saba il
ya des gens il ya des familles
endeuillées et donc nous ce qu'on veut
c'est de sauver des vies le but du
confinement dieu ce troisième futur
confinement ce sera de sauver des vies
c'est pas d'embêter les français c'est
pas de l'esu les parce qu'évidemment on
veut profiter on en a marre moi le psg
je veux passer à autre chose mais ce
confinement là et bien encore une fois
il sert à sauver des vies en attendant
la campagne de vaccination vous êtes
vous êtes pour un gros confinement dur
le confinement qui sera le plus efficace
c'est à dire peut-être le plus strict
principe pour que on en finisse le plus
rapidement possible fermeture des écoles
la question des écoles et délicat
puisque on sait que on a peut-être
sous-estimé l'impact est ce qu'on peut
si on peut mettre une petite critique
c'est qu'on a trop dit non vous
inquiétez pas les écoles on les laisse
ouvert peut-être qu'on aurait dû être un
peu la grande question est là l'enjeu
est ici pour jouer c'est une bonne chose
qu'on ait laissé les écoles ouvertes
d'un point de vue social pour les
enfants de l'école a été catastrophe qui
l'année dernière donc on comprends je
souhaite parce que aussi pour les
parents c'est à dire que pas de la
gueule ouverte à dire que les parents
doivent rester à la maison ou bien voilà
parce qu'il faut avoir quelqu'un qui
garde les enfants est allée au travail
donc en fait la grande question de ce
confinement
s'il est serré ou pas la grande question
ces écoles ouvertes mais connaît bien
mais pour moi un confinement street ces
écoles fermées un confinement
voilà serré mais pas trop strict
séquence ouverte c'est la grande
question
on se dirige vers quoi nicolas dupont
aignan vous vous êtes pour un
confinement céret ou à confinement voilà
comme on a pu le voir là entre
couvre-feu confinement hermach école
ouverte je vais vous dire le premier
confinement je les accepte et et le
raisonnement du docteur je les accepte
et totalement
c'est en mars dernier il ya les masques
on n'était pas au point sur les tests il
n'y avait pas de recul n'est pas de facs
premier confinement on peut l'accepter
le deuxième déjà c'est qu'il ya eu des
erreurs de fait parce que l'eau
metz l'organisation mondiale de la santé
très claire elle écrit les confinements
c'est la pire des choses c'est la pire
des choses mais on est parfois obligé
premier confinement j'accepte le
raisonnement le deuxième c'est qu'on a
échoué sur beaucoup de choses
et alors le troisième un an après c'est
qu'on n'a pas fait ce qu'on aurait pu
faire pour l'éviter
est ce que je trouve absolument
scandaleux c'est de se dire qu'on va
avoir un confinement à perpétuité parce
que des mesures de protection n'ont pas
été prises quelles mesures de protection
juste nicolas ramel sur yon présent même
si jeudi par les produits de protection
aimé mais vous savez pas ce que je vous
raconte n'a rien dit du tout je voudrais
juste m'arrêter sur ce que vous venez de
dire nicolas dupont aignan là vous nous
parler de choses qui n'ont pas été
faites ça et qui peuvent encore être
faites
oui mais justement est ce qu'elles
peuvent être contaminées à ce que sinon
oui si on sait pas où on s'est planté et
si le seul mais il ya un moment on peut
pas été d'abord je voudrais dire le
confinement c'est une destruction
sanitaire parce qu'à tous les gens pas
soigné de d'autres maladies c'est une
destruction sociale
ce écologique économique absolument
monstrueuse c'est dramatique ce qui se
passe donc trois fois de suite le pays
ne s'en relèvera pas donc il faut
bloquer éviter le confinement et je vais
vous donner trois exemples et je vais
vous faire sourire et malheureusement
c'est grave quand je suis venu la
dernière fois chez lui un an
j'ai demandé le contrôle des frontières
j'ai parlé de l'asie j'ai dit voilà ce
qui se passe en asie
voilà ce qu'ils font ils bloqueraient
frontières ils font des tests
quarantaine et tout si on veut régler le
problème il faut peut-être le
confinement mais il faut bloquer les
frontières tous vous m tomber dessus
c'est pas les mêmes qu'un pas tout le
monde mais tombait trop bien foutu tout
le monde dehors tout le monde m'est
tombé dessus on m'a fait passer pour les
vrais fascistes le dingue
pendant des mois j'ai réclamé le
contrôle des frontières
on m'a dit c'est pas possible le premier
ministre le ministre on dit du point il
n'en sera pas non ils y viennent mais
ils le font pas ils ne font pas bien la
solution pour éviter à terme un
confinement à perpétuité c'est de
contrôler les frontières je préfère est
enfermé dans mon pays est enfermé à
domicile parce que c'est ça le choix
mais je remets points c'est ce qui se
passe en asie les colibris en masse et
en asie au resto la vie éco démo live
here on l'a tous marchent parce qu'ils
ont eu le courage de dire on rentre pas
mais nous ya l'idéologie sans frontières
y sont rentrés le et c'est pas possible
de
même pour aller à dire celles d'hawaï
oui c'est deuxième point parce que c'est
grave ça c'est que je veux qu'on passe
d'une logique de protection des
personnes en danger
plutôt que d'en fermer toute la france
et je vous donne un exemple
j'en ai amené le masque ffp2 ce masque
ffp2 j'ai été invité comme chef de parti
à toutes les réunions
interministérielles ddi réunion
interministérielle premier ministre mini
tout le bazar et tous à chaque fois je
leur dit combien de masques ffp2 vous
commandez quand est-ce que vous en
donnez aux personnes âgées
mais quand est ce que vous les
distribuer aux personnes vulnérables 15
millions de personnes vulnérables
on sait pas on sait pas et tout à la fin
monsieur véran me dit on peut pas madame
merkel madame merkel anglais anglais là
elle a envoyé à 27 millions de foyers de
personnes âgées un lot de 15 masques
ffp2 vous pouvez avoir un confinement
demain la petite personne âgée qui la
messe que masque en tissu qui protège
pas équivalent à déverser qu on a dit
que ça serait une catastrophe le maïs en
attendait à yale va quand même mal gagne
confinement aller acheter son paquet de
brad une fois par semaine elles risquent
beaucoup plus que s'il ya pas de
confinement et qu'elle amasse café la
justice qu'elle me dit c'est plus donc y
en a ras-le-bol alors ce chantage je
vous le dis très clairement ce chantage
permanent si vous êtes contre le
confinement est d'enfermer tous les
français c'est que vous êtes un horrible
bonhomme qui veut tuer les gens je ne
l'acceptent plus ya plus d excuse et le
troisième point où je dis qu'il faut
protéger n'a pas fait les trois pôles
encore il y en a deux frontières elle
une troisième masque une protection
ciblé d'accord parce que il faut
protéger les gens qui risquent quelque
chose est sûre c'est ce que dans l'art
est évidente mais et dernier point le
troisième point est là c'est de soigner
les français parce que l'on va
m'expliquer pourquoi ce que vous avez
envie d'un vaccinez vous attendez
pourquoi ce gouvernement non moi mon âge
encore chez limites non ça va sûrement
pas mort ça va être votre mais je vais
vous répondre après attendait à voir
avec 20 à vous je suis pas dans un débat
à eux bel air mais avant je reviens sur
les soins pourquoi se fait-il qu'en
france le ministre de la santé refuse
des études indépendantes sur tous les
soins possibles ivermectine
l'ivermectine est celle analyser mais
utilisés par les réanimateurs j'en ai
rencontré hier
l'ivermectine imaginez on utilise juste
l'hiver mais utile a pas le droit
d'utiliser en médecine de ville envoie
l'argument c'est un bâtiment ou encore
les soigner les gens moi ce que
j'aimerais qu'ils finissent ans
là on n'est pas là on n'a pas le droit
oui oui mais là on trouve pas des
solutions la somalie et nous reste ce
qu'elle est il faut d'une manière dont
les choses viennent je trouvais les
enfermer et donc vous n'êtes pas pour
lui pour tout éviter par des frontières
des masses et rona est trop tard mais
cachez vous dire une chose on va fermer
le pays on va vous mettre sous terre
pendant combien d'années à chaque
variant on va dire il ya des grands
professeurs là qui vont nous dire on
peut pas il ya d'autres solutions
il ya des pays qui vivent là et pays kim
est vrai mais c'est sur eux attention je
suis pas pour être l'axé je ne nie pas
l'épidémie
je ne nie pas les difficultés je ne nie
pas les morts mais quand est ce qu'on va
protéger les personnes vulnérables dont
ils croient neovacs à vous y croyez ou
pas de vaccin ça dépend du vaccin n'y
croyais pas mais je suis franc le vaccin
classique qu'ont utilisés les chinois me
paraît beaucoup plus sûr que le vaccin
arn nous on n'a pas de retirer vu qu'en
israël on vaccine mes maux de tête et
moi j'attends patch 22 du protocole
files heures je n'ai sûrement pas soldés
sur moi y'a marqué quoi que et tu alors
on dirait du villarreal au camp nou
monsieur fisher je suis ni juste
monsieur fisher oui c'est pas le temps
du maire de monsieur monsieur max à
monsieur maxence qui dit à monsieur
fisher / afp l american extraordinaire
dans ce pays iny sur rtl monsieur fisher
avanthier la deuxième radio de france
oui oui il dit quoi
je ne sais pas si ce vaccin protège de
plus de trois mois et je ne fais pas ci
s'empêche de transmettre
de toute façon même s'il marche et qu'il
est génial et je le souhaite voir ont
des soucis marche je souhaite tous
pendant neuf mois
il suffira pas ils sont pas capables de
livrer donc il faudra peut-être protéger
les français
masques frontières soins et si on fait
ça on peut perdre être évité on peut
peut-être et envoyer le confinement
matelas contraire si ensuite étudiants
répondant le dire j'aimerais qu'on
entend de deux secondes
benjamin et après onze jours et jimmy
conclut et qui nous disent qu'il a pensé
de ce tout ce qu'a dit nicolas dupouy là
bas il va mal je sais soir sur quoi
arracher va vous défoncer sur le
confinement pas bon en tant que prof moi
je considère que le confinement qui
effectivement enfin l'état du pays enfin
vous avez faim ou c'est tout l'état du
pays c'est dramatique économiquement
socialement bien
effectivement on est dans une situation
explosive voilà est donc bien évidemment
moi ce que je veux vraiment on peut me
taxer de tout mais certainement pas de
sympathie pour les maquereaux nist et je
pense que s'il arrive au confinement
c'est que pour eux c'est politiquement
la pire des solutions c'est l'aveu d'un
échec
ils ont beau dire regarder partout
ailleurs et c'est compliqué c'est l'aveu
d'un échec
donc maintenant on a une situation on le
voit bien les variants la contagion
explose on a des chiffres il ya des pays
où ça devient une véritable hécatombe
et donc on sait que le confinement ça
marche voilà donc là dans une situation
d'urgence je pense qu'il faut s'y
résoudre aussi compliqué que cela soit
maintenant le problème c'est qu'il faut
forcément derrière avoir une autre
temporalité et que bien évidemment que
derrière il y a des choses enfin moi
vous savez je n'ai pas une mémoire
tampon de 30 secondes
emmanuel macron il nous a dit en avril
dernier en avril 2020 il faut tous se
renouveler - le premier qu'est ce qui a
changé
je vais vous donner un exemple simple
l'entreprise sanofi
elle décide de supprimer 400 emplois
dans la recherche pharmaceutique
aujourd'hui en pleine pandémie mais
qu'est-ce qui est las de ce qu'est ce
qui est mis en place et bien le
gouvernement fait un chèque en blanc aux
entreprises sans aucune contrepartie
on n'a rien sur la relocalisation on est
à poil et donc derrière
bien évidemment qu'il va falloir
demander des comptes à ce gouvernement
qui est un gouvernement d'idéologues et
un tiers d'instable m'embête jamie
murray continue à fermer des lits
d'hôpitaux jim et moi avec la continue à
fermer des lits oui mais il faisait
humide gimmick on n'a pas entendu alors
malheureusement monsieur dupont-aignan
beaucoup de contre-vérités s'alimente
justement la confusion dans la tête des
français
une urgence à faire quelque chose et
quand on explique aux gens qu'ils sont
confinés c'est que vraiment on n'a pas
le choix et que plus on tarde plus que
ce confinement sera dur à vivre et sera
long donc plutôt que on laisse traîner
en longueur qu'on en finisse il ya un
conflit menant place on sera tranquille
cet été ou pas on peut espérer si on
gère bien la suite confine pas n'importe
comment qu'on vaccine massivement et que
monsieur dupont aignan se fait aussi
vacciner parce qu'il va falloir une mine
à l'école continue max à signer quand un
vaccin protéger ni trembler mais ça
c'est complètement délirant ce que vous
pouvez dire alors
pour revenir sur le 35 du protocole fait
oui alors il faut comprendre livre bleu
y est on est en phase 4 qu'est ce que
c'est que la phase 4 e vous savez c'est
quoi la façade des médicaments fin de
mai qu'est ce que c'est que la face qu'à
la médicaliser l'isi mais vous voulez ce
père qui expliquait la page 22 au 24 mai
différents koala prié les effets un test
tous les effets mais ça veut dire quoi
les effets tous les effets secondaires
sommes qui sont vaccinées ça veut dire
qu'une fois qu'on a mis en place le
médicament on va continuer de surveiller
les effets secondaires et l'efficacité
c'est une mesure de protection non quand
il dit qu'on va continuer jusqu'en juin
2022 c'est pour protéger les gens et pas
comme les voir comme les curieux de s'en
servir comme cobaye en ce qui concerne
les personnes âgées vous avez langlade
personnes âgées vous savez qu'il n'a pas
été testé sur les plus de 85 ans alors
voici quand ça allait perdre l'âme phase
iii il n'a pas été testé chez le finir
parce que personne n'est personne le
soin des personnes âgées les personnes
âgées tombent pas malades parce qu'elles
n'ont pas de masques ffp2 elle tombe
malade puisqu'elles ont vu leurs enfants
leurs petits-enfants le cercle familial
qui si elle avait à masquer la marina
supplémentaire mais on tombe malade
lorsqu'on enlève le masque alors ce
qu'il faut bien comprendre plutôt on est
confiné pluton sera déconfit nelhomme
salue donc on aura un revers les langues
non ce n'est pas enfermé ces deux
mesures de protection c'est une mesure
d'urgence en attendant la vaccination
il ya urgence à le faire regarder ce qui
s'est passé au royaume uni cent mille
morts aux etats unis
quatre cent mille morts deux cent mille
morts au brésil et dont je garde
on s'achemine vers l'est semblait on
l'aperçoit seuil et en asie compas
confié je ne suis pas mon la brésil
lespinas cyril hanouna
mais maintenant j'ai pris l'habitude
fausse défendent ici j'ai bouffé eux et
c'est là bientôt regarder les gardiens
2 % et cela on sort du confinement
on va en fait mais est ce que vous
réalisez les dégâts sociaux
oui oui c'est logique collatéraux a oui
on est jeune on est déjà mais alors on
va recommencer tous les trois mois parce
qu'on prend pas les mesures de
précaution je ne demande pas qu'on leur
a soumis un tout le monde se plante
alors nicolas dupont aignan parce que
quantité pour blaguer du congo et s'est
présenté deux fois la présidentielle il
a échoué il se représentera la troisième
fois peut être
donc c'est pas forcément j'avais un
échec gérald et cameron jamie je lui la
fa cup exactement
voilà la question n'est pas là zut je
voudrais vous dire c'est pourquoi des
pays d'asie qui ont une stratégie
rigoureuse qui contrôlent la frontière
protège les citoyens fragile qui confine
les quartiers pas en traitant les eaux
usées les quartiers où il ya des
poussées épidémiologique qui isole les
personnes malades
enfin il ya peut-être un moment on va
sortir du moyen-âge en france il ya
peut-être quand même moment on va
arrêter de manipuler l'opinion d'ubs ya
peut-être un moment où on va prendre des
décisions rigoureuses protectrice je
suis pas du tout pour bien évidemment
qu'il savait rien on sera obligé de
recombiner éternellement ira plus pays
il n'est plus alors l'échelle mondiale
et tiré sur la voie lente et qu'elle est
allée chevaliers du ciel juste derrière
se frottent les mains les chinois et
tout est ouvert et 1er juillet dernier
où il ya plus de tests nasale juste eu
le test annales race raoult d'arc à
l'habitude le test annales maintenant
mais non il est plus efficace
alors il ya une élimination digestif du
corona virus on sait qu'elle n'a donc tu
jesse soit qu'on a eu la diarrhée donc
l'idée c'est peut-être de le faire mais
pas en france je vous rassure
en revanche l'enjeu c'est les tests
salivaires à domicile puissent le faire
avant d'aller au restaurant de nicolas
de me suis fait tester régulièrement
d'accord ce que j'ai dans ma famille une
personne qui est malade
accor âgées et je suis très prudent et
je pense qu'on arrivera à surmonter
cette crise en se faisant en
responsabilisant les gens en leur
apprenant les gestes barrière pas en
lait pour traitant en gamins d'ailleurs
c'est très intéressant il a dit faut
siffler la fin de la récréation
mais est ce que vous vous rendez compte
de l'éruption sociale qui va y avoir
est ce que vous savez ce que c'est ce
qui va se passer dans nos villes
les gens ne supportent plus d'être
enfermés donc c'est facile de dire c'est
la fin de la récréation à merci ses
sauvegardes êtres humains